Have you seen the Liquid Death water company?
Yeah, this company is valued at $700 million.
They literally sell water in a can.
And yes, it's in this like “tall boy”
can.
And yes, it's got like the over-the-top death
metal aesthetic, but it's just water.
I think what this shows us is that Liquid
Death understands how human brains work.
We think we're like rational people who go
out and, like, buy things because they're
useful to us.
Like we're going to go buy water because we
need water.
That's not what's happening here.
They're nakedly showing just how powerful
branding is because they're getting people
to buy a product that is objectively worthless
because it looks kind of cool and edgy and
weird and counterculture.
Liquid Death is about signaling to others
and maybe yourself a little bit that you are
anti-establishment and that's freaking brilliant.
Whoever's in charge of the marketing over
at Liquid Death deserves an A+.
And now, after thinking about this, it's like
I can't stop thinking of all the other things
that I purchase in my life that aren't about
the product, but are about what buying the
product says about me.